foreign
keeping with one of the major and most
unfortunate themes of the year if the
final daily cancellation of the year was
dedicated to the groomers in fact
because I'm a fair person today we're
going to give the groomers a hearing we
are going to let them defend themselves
we are going to listen to whatever
arguments they might be able to put
forward in their own defense
um I have long believed that it's not
possible for us to make a more
compelling case against leftism then the
leftist makes himself against himself if
you simply let him speak that was the
idea behind my film what is a woman and
today we will apply it to this
specifically to the suddenly quite
common phenomenon of the all ages drag
show last week we told you about the all
ages drag show in Texas covered by a
journalist named Taylor Hansen
it was a Christmas themed show which is
currently touring the country and which
includes graphic talk about sex graphic
performances of simulated sex uh
half-naked and nearly fully naked men
parading in front of the crowd
cross-dressing men with fake breasts Etc
it is graphic it's sexual it's obscene
and it's advertisers to all ages
how can it possibly be defended
Well it can't obviously but the left is
giving it their best try as typified by
this Twitter thread from an a so-called
investigative journalist named Stephen
monocelli
it's very important to Stephen
apparently that he defend the honor of
half-naked cross-dressers who perform
simulated sex acts in front of
Elementary schoolers very important to
him he's very passionate
about allowing these sorts of displays
and he posted a lengthy Twitter thread
with that goal in mind let's read
through it he says quote
right-wing activists working with the
Blaze TV and Texas family project must
have realized that protests outside of
drag shows which often feature sexual
language and are always outnumbered but
don't look great don't don't look great
so they've taken the tactic of filming
drag shows for Selective outrage Hansen
and Sarah Gonzalez from The Blaze are
happy to play fast and loose with the
facts Hanson claims the drag show that
is touring Texas right now is family
friendly their advertising doesn't say
that what it says is all ages welcome
this is not unlike an R-rated movie
here's another piece of info about the
show that's touring Texas right now
spotted by Parker malloya it explicitly
says it contains adult content
ah okay see you got us he got us these
aren't family friendly drag shows
they're all ages drag shows ha see that
changes everything
what exactly does it change
well it's not really clear in fact
Stephen in an attempt to defend the
sexual performances for children has
only has only somehow succeeded in
making them seem even worse than they
originally than we originally suspected
he thinks that it gets the drag show off
the hook to point out how it advertises
the fact that it has adult content
but because he's a creepy degenerate
himself he doesn't see the problem with
putting the phrases adult content and
all ages welcome on the same poster
the fact that they acknowledge upfront
that the event is sexual in nature and
yet still make sure to note how all ages
are welcome only makes the pedophilic
grooming nature of the whole Affair all
the more explicitly and horrifically
clear
because keep in mind something
the defense up until now
has been that drag shows aren't adult
oriented that's what they've been saying
now they admit that they are adult
oriented but that's okay
because it says adult oriented in all
ages on the poster what
so once again we go from that isn't
happening to it is happening and it's
good
this is always the process this is
always the trajectory every single time
Stephen Compares us to an R-rated movie
once again defending it in terms that
only prove the opposite of the point
that he's hoping to make also although
you you technically can bring a child to
an R-rated movie
nowhere on any R-rated movies poster or
in its promotional material will you
ever see the words all ages welcome
okay if the movie Eyes Wide Shut came
out in theaters tomorrow
and in all the previews it said all ages
welcome
we would agree that it's a major problem
and extremely creepy at a minimum
or maybe at this point we wouldn't agree
I don't know after all the other side of
this debate has now reached the point of
outright defending sexual performances
for children
but what about parents yes the drag
performers themselves deserve all the
scorn and contempt that we can Heap on
them but the parents who actually bring
their children to these events deserve
even more of it
how do they defend it how can they uh
you know what can they say for
themselves
well fortunately the aforementioned
Sarah Gonzalez who has been doing a lot
of great work and important work on this
issue was on the scene for this uh one
drag show in Texas and she asked the
parents themselves why they're bringing
their kids
and here's what they said
the question do you find this to be
age-appropriate for your children
yeah I mean I'm a little more
uh I'm not as conservative but I mean
really it's not any different than I
mean Disney and Disney date they have
similar things like it's really not that
far from it I had sex of my father's
boss
in My Father's Office very honestly like
I'm by positives
do you find this to be age-appropriate
for children do I find this to be
inappropriate yeah for my child yeah
hello are you reaching for my team are
you hungry do you mind me asking how old
she is she's 12 12. she's she knows
about sex and
these sex yeah well I mean she kind of
sees simulated sex in the show she goes
to school she sees simulated sex all the
time
you know what I'm saying it's exposing
sex to them too young
now honestly because there's there's
like this is a little bit more forward
but there's there's innuendo and all
that kind of stuff in Disney I mean
Shrek I mean they're talking about are
you compensating for something there's a
lot of things that they don't
necessarily get
[Music]
yeah I mean it is sexualized but like I
it's it's it is what it is I just think
it's the stigma around it that's you
know which they don't care I've raised
them not to care the sigma run what
around
um you know different sexualities you
know it's just that's not any different
than you know straight people
[Music]
another big riot
so you don't worry that this is like
ruining her innocence or anything no she
needs to know what's appropriate and
know when to
say no consent and what's appropriate
and what's not and how will she know
that if she doesn't see it in a
Safe Way
so her argument is that kids are going
to eventually be exposed to
cross-dressing fetishes who simulate
sodomy on each other anyway so it's best
to introduce them to it in a safe
environment
in other words according to her kids are
going to be sexually harassed and
sexually groomed so you might as well
facilitate their abuse yourself
if you were wondering what these parents
could possibly say for themselves what
defense they could possibly offer how
they could ever manage to justify their
parenting choices well now you know they
can't defend it they can't justify at
the job of a parent of course is to
fight tooth and nail to preserve your
child's innocence
protect their heart protect their soul
protect their minds
not feed them to the Lions intentionally
because you figure that they're going to
be consumed eventually anyway
these are parents who don't care about
protecting their children obviously to
them the most important thing is to
Signal their leftist Enlightenment to
the world
and what better way to do that than to
offer up your own to the LGBT groomers
putting your in putting their innocence
on the altar as a sacrifice
this is what they're really doing
only they won't say it out loud
that is why these parents and everyone
else involved ultimately claim the honor
of being the last people of 2022. to be
canceled that'll do it for this portion
of the show as we move over to the
members block hope to see you there if
not talk to you well no talk to you next
year Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]